2021 was a banner year for science
fiction movies filled to the brim with
kaiju showdowns time loop extravaganzas
and classic franchise fare here's the
question though just how many of these
excellent sci-fi movies have you seen
fish is a movie that blends romance and
drama with the world of science fiction
released in theaters and on streaming
services in february 2021 director chad
hartigan's movie is set in seattle in
the near future in the midst of an
epidemic of an alzheimer's-like illness
known as nia olivia cooke and jack
o'connell star as emma and jude a couple
struggling with the effect of nia on
their relationship and society
littlefish was filmed before covet 19
and was due to be shown at the cancelled
2020 tribeca film festival this means
that its underlying premise is
coincidental but incredibly timely too
entertainment weekly's mary celosi
writes that despite the subject matter
little fish resonates mostly as a love
story she also praises the performances
from cook and o'connell writing they
both bring the cool project a necessary
warmth that sells their relationship
which is the real star here a number of
critics have noted the film's
resemblance to 2004's eternal sunshine
of the spotless mind though this movie
still has its own unique charms celosi
says the sci-fi trapping gives the
film's central question a poetic shape
while jordan rob of the film stage notes
that the details of emotional bonds are
given utmost priority in the story over
extraneous exposition related to light
sci-fi touches
in other words if you're looking for a
love story fit for these trying times
little fish might be the one for you
take a little romance a little sci-fi
and the basic premise of groundhog day
and you've got the map of tiny perfect
things the plot finds kyle allen as mark
a smart teenager stuck in a time loop
who meets catherine newton's margaret
another teenager stuck in the same loop
the two subsequently decide to focus on
finding the tiny perfect things of their
endlessly repeating day released on
amazon prime video in february 2021 the
map of tiny perfect things gathered good
notices for its strong cast and its
emotional resonance mike ward at should
i see it writes this is a detail-driven
meticulously crafted film that stands
apart from its peers with two strong
lead performances a bit of a mischievous
grin and heart firmly entrenched on its
sleeve meanwhile shawnee harris of
culturists says the map of tiny perfect
things is a new spin on young love that
will stimulate your mind and touch your
heart
if you're looking for some superheroes
with your sci-fi then zack snyder's
justice league is here to save the day
this epic hbo max adventure which clocks
in at a mere 4 hours and 2 minutes may
have been met with a mixed reaction from
the critics but dc's fans couldn't
possibly be happier plot-wise the film
is broadly similar to the 2017 movie
justice league superman's sacrifice and
dawn of justice has spurred bats to
unite a team of his super friends to
face off against a major cosmic threat i
don't care how many demons he's fought
and how many hells
he's never fought us
[Music]
not us united
the movie has six chapters and an
epilogue for easier viewing and
characters such as cyborg and the flash
have their stories significantly fleshed
out giving the film a grander scale with
deeper meaning the ages jake wilson
writes this is genuinely a different
film from the earlier justice league and
a much more coherent one a running theme
in the critical response to the
so-called snyder cut is that zack
snyder's strongest and weakest
tendencies are both on display despite
agreeing that the movie earns its
self-importance vultures bilga of b
renotes when you get the best of snyder
you also get the worst
meanwhile gary mcconaughey of glasgow
live says it's big it's brash and it's
bombastic
so if you love dc comics and you love
zack snyder you're sure as heck gonna
love this
launching on hulu back in march 2021
boss level features a hyper violent time
loop a ton of action and frank grillo
playing a badass former special forces
agent what more could you possibly want
in this case roy pulver's loop involves
reliving the day on which he meets a
grisly death forcing him to figure out
who killed him and why so that he can
end the loop and rescue his family in
order to do so he has to find mel
gibson's colonel ventor and avoid a
whole army of killers along the way
grillo in particular drew a lot of
praise for his leading role in boss
level richard roper of the chicago sun
times complements grillo's ability to
carry the film saying that he pulls it
off with a combination of brute force
and light charm indiewire's christian
blavelt also gives grillo high marks
saying the actor gives the film a pulse
he continues he gets you to invest in
roy enough that even without a
controller in your hands you never feel
like you're simply watching someone else
play a video game
known as sunriho in its original korea
space sweepers takes place in a
dystopian 2092 the movie follows a crew
of space junk collectors who find a
robot girl named dorothy who is not only
wanted by the evil corporation uts but
can also be used as a weapon realizing
they can make a heap of money from their
discovery the sweepers hold her for
ransom which turns out to be a pretty
bad idea space weepers stars kim tari as
captain zhang and richard armitage as
uts's elon musk-like gazillionaire
sullivan south korean writer director
joe seung-hee is the man behind the
camera previously known for his 2012 hit
a werewolf boy and 2016's phantom
detective netflix released space
sweepers in february 2021 to mostly
positive reviews daniel hart at
readysteadycut writes spaceweepers is an
energetic space adventure that manages
to slightly emotionally engage the
audience while stimulating them with fun
action sequences while the strangers
charles madetti says space weepers
features lots of explosions
lots of robots and that raw examination
of capitalist class structures we have
come to expect from the best of south
korea's directors
supposedly the last installment of
legendary's monsterverse godzilla vs
kong is directed by adam wingard and
features a host of franchise newcomers
alongside returning faces such as millie
bobby brown and kyle chandler
in godzilla vs kong the gargantuan
titans have been dormant in the three
years since godzilla defeated king
ghidorah meanwhile the hollow earth
theory discussed in godzilla king of the
monsters has gained traction and the
scientific agency known as monarch has
been keeping tabs on kong on skull
island however a mysterious force
agitates godzilla into attacking the
tech organization known as apex
cybernetics and it's not long before
kong has been co-opted into searching
for the hollow earth's power source
these threads eventually converge when
godzilla's kong sense kicks in
reigniting their ancient rivalry upon
the movie's release in march 2021
critics praised the movie for its kaiju
action with critic peter travers saying
the clash of these titans is spectacular
in every sense of the word possibly the
most glowing praise however comes from
matt zoller seitz who writes that
godzilla vs kong just might be the best
studio film so far this year if it isn't
it's for damn sure the most fun as a
great man once said let them fight
an existentially fraught sci-fi drama
released on netflix stowaway sends three
astronauts to mars on a two-year mission
and then throws a major wrench into
their plans when you guessed it a
stowaway is discovered on board director
joe penna assembled a great cast for
this movie which stars tony collette as
marina barnett the ship's leader on her
final journey into space
anna kendrick plays zoe levinson the
medical researcher while daniel day kim
plays the ship's biologist david kim
unbeknownst to them shamir anderson's
michael adams is also abort albeit
unwittingly and somehow injured
unfortunately whatever caused adam's
predicament has damaged the ship's life
support controls leaving enough oxygen
for only three people in his review of
stowaway varieties owen gliebermann says
hannah takes a mission to mars and
unfurls it on a direct and intimate
emotional level we always feel the
characters could be us
meanwhile christy lemire of
rogerebert.com writes
the movie is a clever take on a familiar
genre with a terrific cast
if you're in the mood for a classic
sci-fi flick with a dark twist stowaway
could be the movie for you
the latest movie from director alexander
aja oxygen has been hailed as a taut
engaging sci-fi thriller in this netflix
french language film a woman named liz
wakes up in a cryogenic pod with amnesia
not knowing who or where she is her only
companion is milo an artificial
intelligence program who advises her
that the oxygen levels of the pod are
decreasing at an alarming rate
if liz can't figure out who she is and
why she's there she'll suffocate best
known for the gory horror of 2003's
slasher high tension and 2019's
alligator thriller crawl aja has been
praised for his restraint with this
particular sci-fi gem filmed during
coveted lockdown from a 2016 script by
christy leblanc oxygen issues the usual
viscera for a more existential sense of
dread as david rooney of the hollywood
reporter writes while cult followers of
aja's extreme horror might be let down
by his turn toward more measured sci-fi
there's plenty of creepy unease packed
into his execution of a simple scenario
that grows increasingly complicated
meanwhile brian talarico of
rogerebert.com notes that this truly
feels like the most pandemic thriller
yet in its own unpredictable way it's a
film about isolation loss and an
uncertain future
the long-awaited sequel to 2018's a
quiet place the quiet place part 2 had
its theatrical only release in may 2021
quickly earning praise from critics and
audiences alike director and
screenwriter john krasinski's
continuation of the abbott family story
also provides a glimpse of the first day
that the sonic aliens arrived allowing
the beloved actor to briefly reprise his
role as lee abbott emily blunt also
returns as evelyn abbott who journeys
with her newborn infant and two older
children in search of a new place to
live after their farm becomes
uninhabitable they eventually come
across killian murphy's emmet a
once-friendly acquaintance with links to
their past
emmett however is now withdrawn and
sullen and abbott no longer knows if she
can trust him a quiet place part 2
received praise for its tight script and
superior use of tension matthew rosa of
salon writes
the film is packed with visceral moments
that stick to your ribs
carrie darling of the houston chronicle
also points out that the film is a
crafty exercise in tension editing and
sound design that never wears out its
welcome
bloody disgusting's megan navarro has
lavished praise on deaf actress
millicent simmons in particular saying
that this is above all simmons show she
nails it so if you were worried about
whether or not this sequel would live up
to the first film rest assured it's sure
to be a terrifying treat for horror fans
the netflix sci-fi flick the mitchells
versus the machines is a kid-friendly
adventure that hit the streaming site in
april 2021 this comedy animation follows
the mitchells a dysfunctional family who
embark on a hectic road trip
unfortunately their vacation turns into
an apocalyptic battle for survival after
the beginning of a robotic revolution
the emphasis on technology as villain
grounds the film squarely in sci-fi
territory as the mitchells who've set
aside their gadgets for an old-fashioned
vacation are thrust into a digital war
the mitchells versus the machines has
been quite the hit with critics which
might come as little surprise
considering it's produced by phil lord
and christopher miller who are otherwise
known for spider-man into the
spider-verse the lego movie and 21 jump
street
bob strauss of the san francisco
chronicle calls the movie a machine
apocalypse for the whole family while
other critics have noted the film's
surprising pro-tech stance how's that
well the guardians benjamin lee writes
rather than the easier and clumsier film
director mike ryonda could have made
scolding kids for swiping and tapping
and missing out on real life he shows
that young digital creators are
achieving incredible things and that
when used right this form of
connectedness can be a powerful force
free guy stars ryan reynolds as the
titular guy a man who greets his
goldfish gets coffee and goes to his job
at the bank once he's there he talks
with his best friend security guard
buddy and this is exactly what he does
every single day as it turns out guy has
no idea he's stuck in a predetermined
loop as a non-playing character in a
popular video game that is until he
meets millie and becomes enamored millie
wants to prove video game impresario
antoine stole the game she developed so
she's looking for proof before antoine
can destroy the game and guy along with
it directed by sean levy free guy
received a number of positive reviews
from critics charlotte o'sullivan of the
evening standard praises the humor in
the movie writing the humor in free guy
is knowing rather than nasty and even at
its most surreal avoids coming across as
indulgent
while robert daniels of the playlist
simply writes free guy is a winner
filmed on an iphone during the covet 19
lockdown the themes of the british film
infant item subject unknown are both
timely and timeless
written by married couple matthew and
tory butler heart and directed by
matthew infant items stars tori as jane
an amnesiac woman trapped in a parallel
world and in a time loop to boot the
film features cameos from sir ian
mckellen as dr charles marland white and
conlet hill as professor aaron
ostergaard both of whom may have
information that could help jane regain
her memory and return to her own world
in particular infinitum subject unknown
has been praised for tory butler hart's
performance for example rachel harper at
sci-fi now writes that the actress who's
frequently alone on screen in the movie
shoulders that responsibility incredibly
well while carrie o'shea of warped
perspective says butler heart pitches it
perfectly given the situations unfolding
around her and she does most of it
without saying anything
critics have also been impressed by how
the movie tackles its heavy and horrific
themes with sarah cartland of caution
spoilers writing that
infant item is a chilling story about
the expansion of human life for a sci-fi
flick that'll satisfy your cravings for
intensity go no further than infinitum
subject unknown
james gunn scores again with his take on
dc super villains in the suicide squad
less a sequel to 2016's suicide squad
and more a reboot of the title this film
brings back harley quinn amanda waller
and a handful of other familiar faces
from the original at the same time
however it brings in a whole heap of new
characters fronted by idris elba's
bloodsport and john cena's peacemaker
once again waller offers a ragtag group
of super villains the chance to shave
time off their prison sentences by
undertaking a secret mission if they go
off script however she'll blow off their
heads cue the mayhem we're all gonna die
i hope so
the seattle times soren anderson writes
of the film
gun masterfully mixes humor and
bloodshed and manages to give a
surprising number of characters room to
develop their personas and when it comes
to staging set pieces he's at his best
while ollie richards of empire writes
when gunn took on guardians of the
galaxy he turned nonsense into gold for
marvel by giving the suicide squad the
same sense of mischief and an equally
surreal streak he's done the same for dc
frank herbert's dune has long been
considered an unfilmable science fiction
novel but that hasn't stopped people
from trying first there was the 1984
david lynch film and then the 2000
miniseries and now its latest cinematic
incarnation has arrived and it's pretty
darn good too
director denny villeneuve wisely
presents only a portion of frank
herbert's epic original novel in a way
that's both satisfying as a movie in
itself and as an introduction to the
events to come dune is set in 10 191 a
year in which house atreides is tasked
by the emperor to replace the ruthless
harkenans as overseers of the planet
arrakis harvesting its coveted spice and
keeping an eye on the indigenous fremen
the harkonnens are less than pleased
about this of course and a devastating
conflict quickly erupts timothy chalamet
stars as protagonist paul artradis the
son of duke leto artradis and his
consort lady jessica artradis he leads a
cast that includes such stars as zendaya
dave bautista and jason momoa audiences
and critics alike have fallen in love
with denny villeneuve's dune for example
salon's melanie mcfarland writes
it is a gorgeous sensory immersion that
holds us in its spell for hours with an
ending that sparks yearning to see what
comes next
meanwhile the av club's ignati
vishnovetsky notes that although the
story may feel inconclusive the
resulting film is a rarity among the
over long effects heavy blockbusters of
the last decade one actually wishes it
didn't have to end so soon
in director miguel sapochnick's finch
which hit apple tv plus in november 2021
a solar flare has scorched the earth
turning the planet into a
post-apocalyptic nightmare tom hanks's
finch weinberg a robotics engineer has
managed to survive along with his helper
bot dewey and dog goodyear unfortunately
finch is dying to ensure his pooch's
survival after his death finch creates a
new robot to care for him this robot
chooses jeff for its name
but after finch's work is interrupted
jeff is left with the same developmental
stage as a child it's then up to fence
to parent jeff so that he can grow and
care for goodyear finch is tailor-made
for people who love dogs children robots
and tom hanks and it's also a really
gorgeous movie thomas lafley of variety
praises the movie's visuals adding finch
offers the right kind of big budget
cinematic escape to viewers young and
old one that's as endearingly uplifting
and disarming as a devoted good boy's
unconditional company as you might
expect hanks is phenomenal with the
austin chronicles richard whittaker
writing if there is a cinematic
embodiment of hope it may well be tom
hanks
as you may have heard many of the
reviews for marvel studios superhero
epic eternals weren't exactly great
sometimes though you have to disregard a
lousy score on rotten tomatoes and go
with your heart or in this case the
audience score which stands at an
impressive 80 percent academy
award-winning director chloe zhao
grounds this cosmic tale of race of
immortal beings in basic human emotions
such as love and sacrifice the ten
eternals arrive on earth to defeat the
deviants aliens who are hell-bent on
destruction once that's done the
eternals remain to observe and
occasionally assist humanity throughout
history but they're instructed by their
celestial leader ereshim not to
interfere in human affairs however
thousands of years of observing the
worst of human behavior begins to wear
on some eternals and when aresham
finally reveals the eternal's true
purpose in nature all hell breaks loose
it's worth bearing in mind that not all
critics slammed this film nina lee combs
of the chicago reader says eternals is a
genuine delightful character development
nestled inside of a complex and
challenging narrative speaking in
defense of the film peter travers of abc
news writes what you'll remember is the
quiet at the heart of the storm and the
intimate connections that zhao values
above spectacle different you bet but
it's also what makes eternals unique and
unforgettable
spider-man no way home earned a
sparkling slate of reviews and reached
dizzying heights in box office revenue
in record time in this installment in
the mcu peter parker's identity has been
revealed to the world forcing immense
pressure onto parker and his friends and
family with nowhere else to go parker
asks dr strange for help and
inadvertently tears open the walls of
the multiverse hello peter
[Music]
spider-man no way home has received
especially high marks for being a film
both die hard fans and casual film goers
can enjoy carrie darling of the houston
chronicle wrote no way home is a deft
funny and surprisingly emotional
superhero adventure that manages to
provide both fan service for the marvel
faithful and breezy entertainment for
those who wouldn't know peter parker
from peter jackson empire's dan joellen
offered similar praise and added that it
won't just make you cheer it'll make you
want to hug your friends too
in the german sci-fi romance i'm your
man marin eggert stars as alma an
archaeologist who agrees to participate
in a unique three-week study
the product being evaluated is a robot
named tom who has been programmed to be
her perfect match depending on alma's
verdict tom and others like him could be
granted human rights can artificially
intelligent beings fulfill the romantic
needs of someone who's single should
such robots have freedom and can alma
even begin to answer those questions
the deep ambition that fuels i'm your
man has been rewarded with widespread
acclaim
stephanie zakirek of time magazine says
i'm your man is funny in such a gentle
way that you may not realize how
piercing it is until after the credits
have rolled
the av clubs a a dowd also praised the
cast for keeping the balance of frothy
to thoughtful right where it should be
this unique film has more on its mind
than whether the girl gets the boy and
is all the better for it
in the matrix resurrections director
lana wachowski returns to the dystopia
of the matrix keanu reeves is back as
thomas anderson this time working as a
famous game developer whose most popular
creation is a video game called the
matrix but mr anderson keeps flashing
back to another life while his therapist
tries to keep him grounded in reality
it's not long before neo is back in the
real world and eager to search for his
true love carrie anne moss's trinity
trinity believes she is tiffany however
a normal mother and wife and it's up to
neo to free her from this new life the
matrix resurrections could easily have
been a soulless cash grab but instead
it's a deeply romantic and hopeful film
that deconstructs nostalgia and explores
complex ideas such as choice and purpose
fox's emily vanderverf praised the film
for its nuanced portrayal of trauma
while noel d lilly of the chicago reader
wrote the matrix resurrections is a
breath of fresh air in a time when
reboots are a dime a dozen
director cion sono's gore-soaked
sensibilities are on full display in
prisoners of the ghostland nicholas cage
gives a superb performance as hero a
criminal who is forced by the governor
of samurai town to rescue a kidnapped
girl named bernice from the mysterious
ghostland this unique movie mashes up
science fiction western grit dystopian
drama horror and samurai cinema into one
completely unforgettable experience
while some critics found this collision
of genre a little much others praised
prisoners of the ghost land for its
sheer audacity the independence clarice
lockri said
sono may indulge in madness but it's not
madness without reason megan navarro of
bloody disgusting writes prisoners of
the ghostland is a neon drenched
spaghetti western full of idiosyncratic
humor and violent social messaging a
triumph for bizarro cinema
the film has also received kudos for his
commitment to an out there storyline
while screen daily's tim grierson
praised cage's performance as the
high-spirited heart of the production
although it's not for the faint-hearted
prisoners of the ghostland is very much
a thrill ride worth taking check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]